this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Monday the 3rd of
April the joint is brought to you by the
freeze pipe are you suckers ready for
420 freeze pipe the makers of the
smoothest heading pipes bubblers and
buns is running the biggest sale of the
year until 4 20. you got
17 days to strike the secret with the
freeze pipe is the freezable glycerin
chambers that comes on every piece plop
one of these Chambers into the freezer
for an hour when you light up the smoke
passes through the chamber and it's
cooled by over 300 degrees when you're
taking pups they're so smooth you don't
even know if the bowl is lit no more
chest pains no more throat pain no more
coughing like a [__] runaway just icy
smooth Puffs to the easy on the body and
full of flavor listen they just sent me
the new [__] tornado oh my God I
can't wait to try this [__]
tonight for the [__] game freeze pipe
is non-toxic freezes more quickly than
water and stays Frozen for longer so the
party never has to stop start smoking
like a [__] king without paying a
king's Ransom by visiting the freeze
pipe.com real quick I love this company
with all my heart
they do a great job with [__] bongs I
mean a great job with [__] bongs okay
this new tornado bung they call it the
travel bung you gotta check this
[__] out so do me a favor
see something you like that's not on
sale use code Diaz Diaz and get 10 off
your entire order that's thefreeze
pipe.com to check out their 420 sale and
use code Diaz for a 10 off your order
order today and say goodbye to hard
smoke and I'll tell you what you're
gonna have a good time with this Bond
when you see the position that they put
into it your [__] Smoke's gonna come
out of your ears right now go to the
freeze pipe and use code Diaz the joint
is also brought to you by oh my God this
Saturday UFC 287 fight card in full
[__] effects it's perea against
adesanya you got Burns against [__]
Monster Ball get out of the action right
now by placing your bet with DraftKings
Sportsbook right now they're doing it
again new customers you bet five dollars
in a pre-fight money line and get 150 in
bonus bets when the fighter wins okay
who do I like this week it's [__]
Monday guys check with me on Saturday
morning and I'll have something for you
on Instagram to really spice things up
combine multiple UFC 287 bets into one
even bigger payout DraftKings same game
Pollies using DraftKings makes watching
an exciting fight even [__] better
you get some onion dip you invite some
of your buds over prove your loyalty by
putting your money where your mouth is
do me a favor guys come on you're
missing out on the game tonight you got
the UFC you got NBA winding down
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
now use code Joey
j-o-e-y new customers bet five dollars
in a pre-fight money line and get 150 in
bonus bets if the fighter wins this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook with
code Joey j-o-e-y minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply she show
notes for details now without further
Ado let's get this [__] party started
foreign
[Music]
what's happening you Savages it's Monday
April the 3rd the first quarter of the
year is gone I hope you got something
accomplished time is moving [__] fast
Jack I don't even know where the [__] is
going half the time but think about it
the first quarter is gone now we got the
second quarter which runs till [__]
June and we got to really pick it up
then because the third quarter is the
summertime people relax see while you
people last in the summer Savages like
me would go to work because I knew
everybody else was [__] creeping
while you're sleeping but then you got
the fourth quarter which is [__] in
September and guys October and that's
when you got to go For Broke you got to
end the [__] year strong but the
first quarter is already gone
I did not know this listen guys you know
you just live for the day sometimes so
you don't even pay attention even though
I'm patreon every morning I go hey it's
Monday the 27th hey it's you just don't
even realize it's April [__] first on
Saturday and you don't realize that it's
April 8th next Saturday and it just and
the [__] hits keep coming you know
what I'm saying but listen it's how you
look at it I'm excited about Easter
it's [__] holy week this week that's
always uh this week always [__] with me
a little bit first off we're gonna get
[__] with a lot because my daughter
has no school as of Wednesday really
Wednesday Wednesday half day Thursday no
school Friday no school and all next
week no [__] school so
that changes me right away it's spring
[__] break people are jumping up and
down
but Holy Week
dog every time I think I like yesterday
came to me on Palm Sunday I was at the
Little League field and I seen people
drive down with Palms I'm like holy [__]
it's Palm Sunday am I slipping as a
Catholic I forgot all about it and then
next week is [__] Easter I did give
up meat on Fridays and I stuck to it you
know I [__] stuck to it the one
Friday I cheated was because the pope
said you could eat corned beef so I just
had a little piece of corned beef
you know I'm not going to go to hell for
that but you got to do what you got to
do you work all [__] year to eat one
piece of corned beef and now Good Friday
once again away and I was in I was all
[__] in until the pope gave out the
message you could eat fried meat today
so I said [__] it if the pope thinks
it's okay Uncle Joe you'll run with it
but man I think about like
how did I end up a [__] think
how did I end up a [__] criminal with
my upbringing because on these we when I
lived in New York City before New Jersey
before Catholic school I [__] hate it
this time of the year because my mom as
crazy as she was she gave up drinking
this week which is never a good [__]
sign my mom didn't give up drinking for
Lent no no no no she just gave up Holy
Week
that's what it's called in Spanish you
got to respect [__] that giving up
alcohol for lentilence got enough
problems for you to give up alcohol but
my mom gave it up my mom gave up alcohol
[__] Holy Week and I'd be like what
the [__] I couldn't work it for money I
couldn't work it when she was drunk and
asking for stupid [__] when she was
passed out so my life was a [__]
night man and then Thursdays at about
six o'clock that Thursday before it's
the Last Supper Thursday night yeah the
Last Supper once you eat dinner in a
Cuban's house that said no TV Thursday
night
no music
you gotta sit there like a [__] dope
yeah and then Friday there ain't [__]
there ain't no music and no TV all day
Saturday she let me watch wonderama and
you know [__] the rabbit whatever p
peep and all that [__] just to before I
killed myself and then Sunday you were
back to watch TV and do whatever the
[__] you wanted but I hate it this week
but think about it where the [__] did
all that religion go my life because I
didn't do anything with it I mean listen
am I religious
I'm a real religious person which means
what I know who the [__] I am and I know
where I stand if you think I'm going to
go to church every Sunday and sit in the
first [__] Pew with nice people and
look at me in the first Pew with a
basket getting money from people that
I'm not doing that
I love whatever's out there I believe in
God I believe in everything that they
talk about
you know I have a special whatever I go
to church two three times a year I
always hit 7 30 Mass because I ain't got
time to sit there for an hour when I
have
Jesus knows about time when you get old
he's an OG he knows
and uh I got a confession once a year
you know I might step up and get a
cookie if I had a good week and I don't
feel guilty I'll go up and get a cookie
you know you can confess to yourself but
it's [__] crazy that
you know I did that for those three
years or four years when I was a kid I
don't know how long then I went to
Catholic school and I still believe I
still
you know but in the other side of that
coin what about me
all the things I did you know one thing
that stuck out of my mind about church
and stuff that I got turned off to
church in a way that I believed it I
enjoyed it I liked the priest I liked
the nun I never got bothered I never got
molested I never you know I never got
creeped out or anything like that I
always liked it it was uh my experience
with Catholic School
was a rough one [__] going to church
at seven in the morning with nothing in
your stomach for an hour oh my God and
you're [__] hungry and it's cold
that was not for me but I think as I got
older you know things happen and I
stopped going to church when I moved to
Boulder
when I got out of no when I before I got
locked up
the guy who put the time into me Ray
King God bless God Rest his [__] soul
was like listen it'd be a good idea if
you got in
with the church group and
you know just talk to the priest a
little bit try to get a letter of
recommendation from him now guys I'm not
a [__] hypocrite but at the same time
I go let me go down there and talk to
this guy
I was trying to fill a void in my life
so I go let me go down and talk to this
priest the priest's name was Father Tom
I'll never forget this this guy as soon
as I walked in here we just started
talking to my jersey and food and
[__] the Bronx and I don't even think
he was from the East Coast
and he just you know he won me over so I
set up meetings with him and I would go
every [__] week and then we'd talk
about Good Fellas we talk about movies
we talk about Shoot Em Up stuff you know
and I got a little bit involved I made
my confirmation I made my confirmation
when I was like 30 years old because I
was so [__] lost
and uh I started going on Sundays I'm
not gonna lie to you I started hitting
Church you know I thought it would help
a little bit before prison you know
prayer helps you know whatever I don't
[__] know guys I was so [__] lost
and but then I used to sell Chryslers in
Boulder
and
this is really weird a guy came in one
day to buy a convertible
and he came in with a woman I
don't know I just said hello to him I
started talking to him and one thing led
to another we started talking about a
church and he knew my father-in-law at
the time or you know Ray who was like a
great guy in town
and we started talking to my Ray but I I
noticed that when I started talking
about Ray
he started
you know uh
he got a little fishy like his body
language was off if I was 26 this guy
was 50 something you know
and
a couple weeks later I saw the guy in
church to my surprise the chick he was
hugging with in the car was his mistress
because he was at the church with his
wife
but he was also sitting in the first row
and he was also one of those uh shoes
collecting envelopes
and even in my [__] up cocaine World
though look at this guy and I go what a
[__] hypocrite
he's got a wife he you know He Cheats
he's [__] no wonder he would score me
when I started bringing up my
father-in-law and look at him he comes
in here on a Sunday
like nothing and he just sits up in the
front row and he makes believe he's one
of God's children [__] that I don't want
to be around these people if I'm going
to go to church I'm going to go on
certain [__] conditions I sit in the
last row because I'm a [__] peasant I
don't try to be anybody I'm not supposed
to be in that church I've committed a
ton of [__] bad things that was a
long time ago and I'm sure it's forgiven
it doesn't matter I haven't forgiven it
yet so when I go to church I sit in the
back I watch the people that are faking
the funk I watched a few of the real
nice people that are real
tremendous and I you know write it off
and now again am I super religious then
I go to Palm [__] Sunday yesterday do
I have a palm hanging from my [__] uh
driver the visor and all that I don't
do I feel bad about it at times you know
my daughter didn't go to church
yesterday my wife didn't go to church
yesterday you know we played softball we
went to play [__] football with the
kids I mean guys what do you want from
me so I pay attention to the church as
much as I can I think about it I I'm
grateful to God every [__] morning
you know
and I try to live by his rule which is
be nice smoke dope right
I'm not sinning I think God wants you to
smoke dope I mean in my think about it
he it's not cocaine it don't have to
throw gasoline on it it grows from the
[__] dirt right Weedle
yeah I mean that's what it was right the
smoker I mean it comes from the [__]
dirt you know
listen I'm not robbing nobody I go to
sleep at night you know I haven't robbed
anybody in [__] years so
I'm okay with God for right now I mean
we're on an okay basis I
yeah I try to do the best I can I still
try to make everybody's day I'm just not
that [__] guy did I go to church for
Ash Wednesday I love to walk in here
with a thing like Marky Wahlberg and
tell you that I'm I put my faith up for
you know stop
stop
that's all I ask
another great thing that's happened this
[__] week I'm excited about
again for years I was always away you
know but I always tried to watch Final
Four weekend I [__] always just
something about final four weekend that
has always done something and we'll get
to that point later I'm excited about
tonight you got [__] uh San Diego
State against my boys from Jersey City
Yukon I'm gonna watch the [__] game
I'm gonna smoke some reefer I'm out of
mushrooms I might have [__] oh I got
some ABX edibles
so no I don't even eat those Edibles no
more first of all I made a I give them
to Mike when I get them and I really
feel after all this time they're the
best edibles I think honest to God hey
ABX Edibles are [__] on the money and
now I got a new system I throw eight of
them in a milkshake when I when I'm oh
1600 right off the bat Doug
eight twos I throw if I want to sleep
like a baby and hit REM sleep on my
whoop watch that's what needs to be done
okay I'm sick and tired of [__]
getting I didn't get enough REM sleep 20
was Rim I need 35 and the only way I get
it is by going deep deep deep into the
murky [__] Waters so I make a nice
protein shake eight ounces of [__]
water I put a little protein powder in
there I put eight capsules in that here
and I put nine I'm not gonna lie to you
dog I blend them and then when I go to
drink them at the end the capsules come
out hard yeah they don't melt in the
[__] I'm like God damn it so I gotta
[__] squeeze them they taste like
dick to be honest here you squeeze them
you burp it later I eating eight of them
so you you blow a tremendous THC burp
when you're like oh and then it just
well I put them in my milkshake now
and the other day Mr Softee came and I
go hey before you put that in the
blender put these in there he goes what
are they I go there [__] you know uh
oil fish oil for my boy bones because
they don't smell like fish oh no they
don't I drank that whole [__] Mr I
love all that [__] I love those [__]
ABX Edibles man they do not [__] around
and you know I try I guess the Stoners
Club is kaput it was just yeah they just
they they disappeared about a month ago
without even a [__] call or a message
or nothing they didn't call they didn't
send a message I put an order in one day
and I never got it you didn't pay for it
though no no you pay cash when they get
there I put an order on there I never
even got a text the next morning I was
like what the [__] is going on it's like
a week later I went back to the page and
they had two pages of stuff on there
that's it I'm like what the [__]
I called the owner a couple times
never called me back never answered the
phone I sent a few texts and then I went
on there this week and they're gone
start our own delivery service I would
love to I just don't even know where the
[__] to start I I won't I don't even do
it oh yeah it's got to be doable but you
got to have a [__] place you gotta
have a [__] huge safe because people
are robbing those weird places now like
hell I don't know and then you gotta
deliver it God forbid somebody's waiting
for you with a stick
I'm not in the [__] mood to get
mugged at this [__] age
but it's funny I was talking about the
NCAA tournament you know
it's Monday motivation I do one pack
podcast a week now it's the best I could
do and it's basically to get you
[__] up off your ass and my in
a way that only Joey could do it
I read some the other day on online I I
did a podcast for my white belt jiu
jitsu
it's he's on Instagram great [__] guy
and I love what he does and I can't tell
you how many times I've woken up in the
morning and I don't feel good or
something and I go to check my Instagram
he's the first thing up there my white
belt he put some great [__]
motivation things in there you know the
other day he put something in there that
was blowing the [__] away he goes I want
you to start
sitting before class and visualizing
what you want to do during class just
visualize or visualize or visualize it
just take one move one pass and keep
going over it in your mind now you want
to do it and the people and the things
that people will put up to not let you
go to you know fastest guard
and he was just talking about like uh
how you have to keep going for it blah
blah blah
and I was looking at this I'm reading
this I'm like this guy's [__]
he's [__] right from A to Z
what he's saying about you have to
visualize stuff and how I remember is
because
guys I got left back in the seventh
grade and I
I'll tell you guys that made me feel
really [__] shitty I got dumped by my
girlfriend she got a new boyfriend and
then I [__] got left back and to top
it all off I never even seen her vagina
because at least she got left back you
at least did something dirty with her in
the sixth or seventh grade or I didn't
even do nothing dirty we would dry
humping I'd get all worked up and my
cheeks would get red you know you're a
stupid [__] kid yeah you're a stupid
[__] kid
so
when I got left back guys I was in a bad
[__] way I couldn't tell my mother my
friends were looking at me all weeks
that's the dummy you know you got left
back you know what I'm saying they even
put you they put me in another seventh
grade class like the last day of school
they usually introduced you to your
eighth grade class or the class you're
going into they put me into a seventh
grade class and they're like this is
where you're gonna be if you don't go to
summer school well I [__] didn't go
to summer school because I was in love
it happens
and I got [__] left back and I felt
shitty guys and I was trying to feel
good about myself I was going to karate
I was and then I picked up this
basketball I picked up basketball in the
sixth grade I always played as a kid on
the streets I still remember playing in
New York City playing against like a No
Parking side
there could be no parking on a brick
wall and we just have to shoot the
basket to no parking sign that's all
I've been playing basketball
ah
I [__] uh picked basketball it's a
game you can practice by yourself
I was an only child you know what I went
over there and thought about
how I was going to [__] change my
life I just got [__] let back
you know you [__] don't usually you
don't start noting that you're stupid to
like your junior year in high school you
realize that the people around you have
more of a chance than you do
but in eighth grade and the seventh
grade to get your [__] win taken out
of you like that it's brutal I didn't
know what to do so I went to karate
I [__] doubled up on school work I
made sure everything was [__] done I
got all A's and I played basketball
I was ashamed to be around people my
little basketball buddies accepted me so
that's all I would do I would play
basketball play basketball and I watch
pro basketball I would always watch pro
basketball Julia serving Bernard King
you know all those old-time greats
that's what I love
I don't know
one day in the eighth grade
maybe in the seventh grade
I was uh yeah I was left back so I was
in the seventh grade
I don't know another Sunday I was
watching I put something on
and it was college basketball and I was
like okay at that time I used to watch
Rutgers because I was growing up in
Jersey I would try I would I would watch
Rutgers because they had a guy named
James Bailey and he was six foot nine
he'd slam dunk he was okay I don't think
he made it to the pros but that's not
what the story is about
so I just would watch college bat I
wouldn't watch college basketball I
would watch Rutgers but on this
particular day was the final fault
and I turned on this game and it was
North Carolina UNLV
and I was like getting chips you know
like when you a game first comes on
you're like I'll watch this let me get
some chips or a soda whatever the [__] I
was doing I kept there in Jersey City
Jersey City
and I finally sat down I'm watching this
game and
I watched like a half and maybe uh I
watched like three quarters
and I watched the ending of it and
throughout the game they kept mentioning
Jersey City
and then at the end of the game they
[__] uh
they gave the totals North Carolina beat
the UNLV I'll never forget that and they
gave the totals of the players and
they're going to the final four they're
going to the championship game Monday
against Marquette whatever the [__] it
was again guys I'm lost I'm watching
this and they keep talking about Jersey
City
this kid from Jersey City this kid from
Jersey City I can't figure it out so I
don't know I go to the basketball court
after the game and I ask some of the
guys listen man I'm watching the NCAA
Men's Basketball Championship
and they're talking about Jersey City
throughout this whole thing you know I'm
a kid listen I'm from Union City you
know I
when we came from Cuba I lived in
Manhattan and then all of a sudden I was
always in Jersey and my mother had a bar
in Union City and then we moved to North
Bergen
I I don't know I always felt like a man
without a [__] without a home you
know what I'm saying like I I've been at
so many places that I was like well
maybe uh you know
so Monday the game comes on again I'm a
stupid kid I don't know who you know I
know marquette's playing North Carolina
I don't know anything about these two
teams I could sit here and lie to you
and tell you I knew Dean Smith I knew
nothing about these two teams I didn't
even know people played basketball in
Jersey City that's how stupid I was but
Jersey city turns into North Bergen
and uh Monday night the game comes on
and I'm watching the you know the
starting five plays
and guys when they said I'm freshman
from Jersey City New Jersey
I thought I was gonna [__] die
and also Nate a freshman I start whoa
whoa whoa whoa
what you're telling me
it's a freshman
is starting from Jersey City a freshman
not a sophomore not a junior and not a
senior a freshman in the biggest [__]
game of the year of freshmen
and he's from Jersey City New Jersey
guys I dropped what I was doing
you know like when you feel your body
[__] leave you you've had that like
you're watching something of performance
of your favorite band what it could be
cheap trick I don't give a [__] it could
be [__] you know somebody playing
Chopsticks everybody's different every
once in a while you watch something that
it just takes you to a different level
man it just blows you away you know
and at that age I'd never been blown
away over an art there's times I get you
know I'll watch a movie and I'll go [__]
you know how good is [__] Marlon
Brando and The Godfather it's inspiring
it makes you want to be God Gangsta it
makes you want to be an actor it makes
you want to be a producer I mean that's
how good he was all those little nuances
he was doing with his hands he was just
brilliant that and he was always a great
actor but that was his [__]
Masterpiece sometimes you just have a
[__] Masterpiece where everything
comes true
I don't even know what I was talking
about I'm so [__] excited you know
and I watched this kid play and North
Carolina ended up losing that night to
Marquette I found that later it was Al
McGuire's last game at Marquette Jerome
White had all these players Puerto Rican
kid named Butch Lee again I identify
with the Puerto Rican kid Butch Lee
but it wasn't as hard as how I
identified with this [__] Irishman
from Jersey City New Jersey he had acne
the whole thing I just not that I had
acne but Jersey City and North Bergen
and [__] neighbors and this kid just
got onto the [__] biggest stage in
college basketball as a freshman you
know I thought people from Jersey didn't
do anything
I didn't think we did anything you know
I knew Frankie Valli was from Jersey I
knew Evelyn Costello who are from Jersey
you know but that's completely different
I knew Bruce Springsteen Western Jersey
at the time
but
it's different than [__] Jersey City
and it's different it's like when I
found that Sinatra was from Hoboken
Hudson County
it drove me [__] insane guys it that
just that thought alone drives me
[__] insane you know I tell people
all the time A lot of people are going
to get mad at me for saying this
there's Jersey
and there's there's Hudson County and I
tell you this guy with the [__]
strongest reservation in my [__]
heart there really is there's Jersey and
then there's Hudson [__] County and I
guys it's a I know people from Bergen
County I know people from Essex County I
know a lot of [__] people I love them
all I love New Jersey but there's
something about Hudson County that
brings out the [__] Savage in you and
when I thought you know okorin I
followed him dog then a couple months
later
Sport magazine which was
Sports Illustrated only a little smaller
did a cover about his mother she was a
single mom an Irishman and they talked
about how he played so much basketball
he had knee braces on and the knee brace
would cut into his [__] skin and he
wouldn't complain they didn't have any
money you know this was just [__] I
mean I didn't identify with them not
having money my mom had the bar and we
were all well off but I identified with
the single mom thing like he talked
about like she was his life she [__]
encouraged them the Irish the Irish they
don't [__] around but that seeing that
let me know that I could do something
with my life you know what I'm saying
it's [__] crazy as it seems as
excited as I am seeing that
let me know that I could do something
with my life
if he could do it and he's from [__]
Jersey City
I'm gonna give it a [__] a hell ride
and listen it didn't have to be
basketball
it doesn't have to be basketball it
doesn't have to be
comedian that doesn't have to be an
actor you could that motivation you
could take and be a [__] scientist
with
that guy took the same bus as I did he
walked the same streets I did and he
went to the same dirty [__] Courtside
that there were no wooden floors or Nets
on the baskets you know when you went
the whole book on the planet what street
there were [__] metal things with no
you know you had rip you had they put
her [__] net up on in June it took
two months that net was gone once the
net was gone you didn't get one for the
next [__] June you know what I'm
saying so something about that and
you have to look at things that way
sometimes
you don't look at things to hate you
look at things to learn from and grow
from
Jesus Christ I've grown from the most
weirdest things that I've looked at
you know just even something negative
going oh my God you know what as a comic
as a human being as a dad as a [__]
Spanish person as a [__] as whatever
I'm not ever doing that
I'm not doing that
you know there was a thousand things
from a negative turning into a positive
so for me like
I get motivation from the weirdest
[__] places you know patreon I have
this patreon and I talk to a lot of
people on there and they ask me
questions one of the biggest questions
I get whether it's patreon whether it's
Facebook whether it's
Twitter I just got one the I9 that's why
I want to talk about this before time
ran out that
people have a hard time making [__]
decisions
it's really weird for people like
sometimes people hit me with things and
I go
well that's an easy one but it might not
be an easy one to him
and the thing I get hit with the most is
jobs I don't know why like I'm not a
head hunter I don't know anything about
that hunting I really don't
I know about making your life better
I know the steps you could take to make
your life better
you know I've had to make 20 different
times that I change courses in my life
because it's like uh
you ever see the movie Collateral
collateral with uh Tom Cruise and
[__] Ray whatever his name is Jody
whatever his name is Jordy fox fox I
don't know Jamie Foxx Jody Fox Jamie
Foxx I came to the conclusion of one of
the most talented [__] dudes in
Hollywood by far I mean that
[__] could he could do a [__]
anybody's voice he could sing anybody he
does Ray Charles for the [__] T if
you could find his actor's studio
interview you'll be blown the [__] away
but anyway
what can I talk about oh uh
and collateral
there's a scene where he's pissed off at
Jamie Foxx and he goes you know you have
to adapt
what's he did you ever see that movie he
calls it Chi ging like some philosopher
he goes you got to adapt you gotta in
life you have to adapt you know what man
on a weekly level you have to reel
yourself in and go all right what are
they sending at me this [__] week
what am I walking into this [__] week
you have to adapt every week
with jobs guys you're trying to better
yourself
right with a job you're trying to better
yourself so when somebody hits me with a
job when they say Joey I'm in a deep
position I've had this job for four
years the guys that dick had I want to
switch to a better gig what do you think
I got some people like confused about
the drive you know I gotta drive an hour
but I'm making more money everybody has
different issues you know and all those
issues of fear
that issue of not going and listen I get
it
can get it there's nobody more scared
than I was and I tell people it took me
18 months to get on stage
18 months me 18 months to get on stage
procrastinating lying pussying up yeah
if you want me to lie that what do you
guys think I just got the idea oh stand
up yeah I'll get on stage on Monday [__]
you it took me eight months of lying and
bullshitting and giving up those excuses
knowing
knowing that it would change my life how
many times have you [__] stepped on
glass
and you cut your foot I'm just using the
[__] term here whatever and you have
to go to a doctor how long do you put it
off for
some people put it off if I if 10 people
get cut by a piece of glass five of them
will go I'm not going to go to the
hospital they don't want to pay for the
Stitch they all have a different story
they don't have insurance whatever even
though it's going to make you better
people will still do it you know for
years I did cocaine knowing I was going
to die knowing eventually my fat heart
was going to blow up people smoke
cigarettes knowing that one day their
[__] finger is going to fall off or
your lungs gonna fall off or your eyes
gonna fall off you know people go to
Burger King and that's all fine knowing
that you're gonna [__] blood for 10
years that's fine we've all been we've
all done that they're all smoke screens
when you're looking at a job or a
situation to better yourself
you know I get these too hi Joey I don't
know what to do I've been with my
girlfriend for eight years we have a kid
together but I call her I caught her in
bed with eight midgets I don't know what
to do well
if you caught her in bed with eight
minutes they know coming back there's no
Therapy Group that's ever going to save
you from that and again I say midgets
I'm very sorry yeah little people again
you get you you catch you know I got a
[__]
oh my God I forgot what happened to this
girl I got a [__] Facebook about five
years ago but I thought it was just
insane
this girl would write me letters like
not letters Facebook messages
Joey I need to stop getting high
I'm a blackout drunk I don't know what
to do well you gotta [__] stop
drinking you know she was a boozer
I don't know after about a year she
sends me this thing one night said I'm
so ashamed I don't know who to tell
I got so drunk last night I had a
threesome with a pimp and a [__]
and then she sent me the picture of them
in bed like she was crazy This Girl's
Crazy
she blacked out and woke up with a pimp
and a [__] that's and she got pregnant
like she hit me up like a year late I'm
pregnant I had the baby
yeah I don't know I never heard from her
again you know what I'm saying I don't
know what happened there
but it's so funny how it was so scared
to commit it takes us and even after we
commit or [__] petrified you're
[__] petrified you're like what is
the other [__] shoe going to drop you
know what man
when you commit listen if you're scared
of a decision
one of the things that bothers me the
[__] most my biggest pet peeve is me
and Mike talking for an hour but a
decision he's going to make and then he
calls me the week and says he goes
another way duchess
tears me up so I had to do something to
stop that
if Mike comes to me now
I do it the right way I rip a piece of
paper out of a notebook and I do a Ben
Franklin close and let them make the
decision for themselves so I don't feel
[__] shitty about it right or wrong
you don't know what Ben Franklin closes
yes so you take uh Ben Franklin clothes
you know pros and the [__] cons and
you write them all out you take an hour
and then we discuss them and we go what
do you know the whole time I'm already
I'm already there yeah I'm already there
you know
I just want him to I just want you to to
read it and to really absorb it to see
what's going to happen if you're that
scared of making you know how many
people don't do anything because this
[Music]
do you have any idea how many people
are just I don't know the word right now
are just very
I think
like this will be my job
I could stay here for 40 years I'm never
going to try to do anything better than
that and eventually somebody leaves that
job and they'll reach out and go Mike I
got a job over at RC Cola that don't
beat you up as much you get 10 more
dollars to give you benefits nah I think
I'll stay here and that's how they live
their life never trying to reach every
year you should be trying to reach
something every [__] year you know I
still remember making eight thousand
dollars a year
after doing comedy for five years I
started 91 and in
96. I could tell you [__] with
all the honesty in the world I made
eighty six hundred dollars
and the year before that 96 wasn't no
better 95 I made money but I blew that
as it came out as it came in I'm sorry
as it came out my point is that when
you're doing something for five years
and one day you look at your [__] tax
return
and you made 9600 that's not even a
thousand dollars a month
right that's about 800 a month right
eight yeah it's about 800 a month it's
tough to convince yourself
that this is going to be your decision
for the next five [__] years when you
just so at the end of five years what
was I thinking
by the time I do five more [__] years
I'm gonna make sixteen thousand a year
that's even worse than Subway
that's worse than anything I don't know
what who gets sixteen thousand dollars a
year from doing stand-up
so what do you do do you quit
because for a minute there I was like
that hundred thousand that I'm in debt
that's going to take a little longer to
pay off than what I [__] expect it is
so what the [__] do you do
you [__] uh
figure out how to make it better
how can I make this better and then Josh
Wolf Turned Me Out to a company who did
Industrials and what's an industrial
Joey industrial is a video where you
teach people how to do a job so we would
do videos like ups and [__] like that
how to pick up a box you pick up the box
and put it over here I swear to God all
the time we did training videos you know
you figure out the next level
of it had you know when I was making
eighty six hundred dollars a [__]
year I'm like wow and you guys know four
thousand that was going to cocaine
you know the other money was going to
[__] child support or whatnot
I was just breaking [__] even
was I happy [__] yeah I was having the
time my [__] life no responsibilities
getting up late drinking who gives a
[__] hey you owe me 20. try to get it I
only got four dollars in my pocket I'm
minus 16 as it is [__]
foreign
but if you're having a hard time making
a decision Ben Franklin closes
and really think about it and process it
so you never have [__] doubt
you never have a [__] doubt
but half of us think about it
my friend said it's a great job we don't
really [__] think about it I want you
to start doing something it's the end of
the first quarter it's Monday motivation
[__] I want you to think about
something that I had to start doing
about 15 years ago
and I got really bad at it for a long
time guys that's why I'm asking you to
start doing it now when you're young
he said why are you doing this
did you ever ask yourself that
no you haven't you've never asked
yourself why are you doing this
start asking yourself that why am I
going now
what am I getting out of that why am I
doing this
why do I keep doing this
it's like this Thursday and again I'm
going to get a lot of hate for this
it's like Friday or Thursday the Yankees
played the season opener
judge hits a home run
Garrett throws whatever great picture
and now I gotta see all the Yankee fans
yelling again it's our year
it's our year it's our year it's our
year well come July they're all going to
be like this like Nick detour every year
throwing things and yelling
and then by August they're sick to their
[__] stomach
and it's like We All Fall for the same
things all the [__] time the Yankees
win every game opener at home it's the
Bronx they don't [__] lose
like they lost Saturday I'm not
we keep falling for the same stupid [__]
people that's what I'm trying to say
when I did Coke every [__] day like
that what what is the definition of
insanity
what are we talking about here guys when
you make a decision that's what you have
to base it on the Ben Franklin close how
does it affect you and why are you doing
this
are you doing this for the money are you
doing this because this is what you love
nothing inspires me more when I go to
something
and I could see somebody doing something
that they really love
[__] inspiring man and I'm around two
or three people like that now that I
look at them and I go I'm jealous of
this [__] because this guy would
do this for free
he would do it for free every day I
could tell you know you have a session
for 45 minutes you're in there with him
for an hour he's not charging you for
those 15 minutes
it's because this is what he loves
it's easy to him he doesn't give a [__]
same way I was about comedy for years I
was on stage every day I [__] loved
it you get you know you get older things
change in your life situations get
thrown at you and you have to adapt
and see where you're at and then take an
inventory every couple months
but if that's what you know everybody's
talking about all this mental health
[__] now and everything when I was
struggling with my mental health it was
because I I went away from doing what I
had been doing for years
which was writing or thinking about
stuff the last two or three years now I
was living Allah Allah [__] alamook
and I had nobody helping me
I had my management my agency that they
don't do that
and I wasn't doing it
and I wasn't checked you have to check
yourself from time to time the biggest
question is why are you doing this
you know I think about myself not going
to Consciousness I was as a kid now
and I'm honest to say this for people
when I was 18 19 you're trying to be
cool
when you're 17 you're trying to be cool
hey I went to see Led Zeppelin I never
saw that job hey I went to see AC DC hey
I went to third row you know you do all
this [__] because you try now bands come
that I love and I'm like I'm not going
down there
I'm not [__] going down there I don't
want to sit with I got to walk through
miles sit next to heavy metal Joe and
Mott the Hoople they got body odor yeah
I'm not doing that [__] but you know
when when I was a kid I was trying to be
somebody I was trying to be cool now I'm
not trying to be anybody I'm just a
[__] old man that you know is just
trying to [__] live on a daily basis
so check on yourself from time to time
monthly it's like a [__] goal I don't
want you to do it every day what am I
feeling now [__] that today I'm feeling
like a zebra no
just check yourself and why am I even
doing this do I even enjoy this anymore
maybe I'll keep doing it but I'll do it
three days a week just like I did with
the podcast two days was not working for
me guys I didn't have it anymore at
least I'm man enough to admit that but
one day I could come in here and talk
some [__] with you guys on a [__]
beautiful Monday morning to get you
ready for a [__] great week and
that's exactly what I do every week and
I'm having a good time doing it so [__]
it it's not about the money it's not
about [__] knowing this or doing that
it's just about having a good time being
you and doing what you could cover to
spread with and that's your Monday
motivation for April [__] third
[__] it's gonna be a great week I
don't have a pick for tonight I'm
excited I'm leaning towards UConn San
Diego State the defense is [__] great
and that's it boom tremendous the
[__] book now we're getting into the
meat and potatoes of this [__] cocked up
this so it's on now [__] it's
April what is it May 2nd April 23rd I
don't [__] know but the book will be
in your house within three weeks the
audiobook I think is May 2nd and I'm
really excited about this the more I
think about this we did a great [__]
job with this so thank you have a great
[__] week have a great Easter
with your families and stay black
[__] Uncle Joey loves you and now
for a word my [__] sponsors
all right I want to thank you savages
for another Monday morning motivation
the joint is brought to you by
DraftKings listen this Saturday to be
honest with you tonight we got NCAA
Championship game you got UConn against
San Diego State and you can roll your
win into this weekend with UFC 287 perea
against adesano they're gonna face off
again for this middleweight title fight
get it on the action by placing your bet
with DraftKings Sportsbook the official
and official sports betting partner of
the UFC new customers can bet five
dollars on any pre-fight money line and
get 150 in bonus bets when your fighter
wins listen like I said
just get Ready download the [__] app
and get ready to put in a [__] same
game parlay if you want a bigger payout
the more legs you add the more money you
win how long will the fight go will it
go over will it end with a decision a
disqualification
DraftKings makes watching a fight
exciting as ever download the app right
now use code Joey j-o-e-y new customers
can bet five dollars and any pre-fight
money line and get 150 and bonus bets if
that fighter wins this Saturday at
DraftKings Sportsbook use code Joey
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details and oh
[__] it's April and freeze pipe is
offering you a deal of a lifetime it's
the biggest sale of the Year till 420.
bubblers pipes bungs everything they got
pop in one of those chambers in the
freezer for an hour when you light up
and the smoke passes through the chamber
so it's instantly cooled by 300 degrees
that's what the freeze pipe does we're
taking pups so smooth you'll check the
bowl to see if it's even lit no more
coughing no more eyes pop naughty head
no more chest pain burn just icy smooth
[__] pups try this new tornado
it's called the travel bong [__]
tremendous freeze pipe is non-toxic
freezes more quickly than water and
stays Frozen for longer so party never
has to stop listen you could be smoking
like [__] Wiz Khalifa on a [__]
Saturday without paying the king's
Ransom by visiting the freezepipe.com
again the freezepipe.com with the
massive 420 sale going on right now use
code Diaz the 10 off of the entire order
that's thefreeze pipe.com to check out
that 420 sale or use code Diaz for 10
off your order I want to thank Bree's
the freeze pipes and I want to thank
DraftKings for always getting the party
started on Monday but I want to thank
you [__] Savages have a great week
and I'll see you next Monday morning Tip
Top Magoo
foreign